hello there so very recently esposito
did an interview
and just confirmed that the mandalorian
will get seasons three and four
so he says here we're living in a
universe that is huge and there's so
much to explore
so i think this show is going to lay the
groundwork for the depth and breath
that's gonna come in season three and
season four where you're really gonna
start to get some answers
so um season three already was confirmed
a while back
and they're actually currently doing
pre-production on that but he did
confirm
season four here which is really big
news guys
because um there were some rumors about
season two having some background issues
with possibly
pedro pascal leaving production halfway
through and stuff and
people are saying the mandalorian show
is like in trouble and blah blah blah
but you know getting news that season
four's confirmed i don't know loki
debunks some of that or at least
shows you that um they have a lot of
confidence in the show so
i don't think man lauren's in trouble i
think it's in good hands with dave
filoni john favreau
and i'm really excited that you know
season four is confirmed it means
disney's really confident in the show
they're green light and a couple seasons
ahead like
season two hasn't even come out yet and
have confirmed season four
so i think this is actually great news
and i'm really excited to see um how the
story of the mandalorians going to
expand
and you know i wonder how much more
seasons we're gonna get can we possibly
get like up to season seven like the
clone wars
i don't know tell me in the comment
section below what you think of this
news
and how many seasons do you think we're
gonna get over mandalorian anyway i hope
you guys enjoyed this video please leave
a like and subscribe and comment down
below if you'll want more commentary
videos and i'll see you guys
in the next video
[Music]